ah si concorde avait pu bénéficier du
même enthousiasme de la part des
compagnies aériennes mais concorde
s'il représente un merveilleux appareil
est aussi un échec commercial dans les
prochains jours ou encore d' accueillera
son 500.000e passagers 250000 pour air
france et autant pour la british airways
mais la facture kérosène s'alourdit pour
les quatre concorde d'air france cette
année elle s'est élevée à 300 millions
de francs l'équivalent du prix de 2
litres de super pour chaque français
quatre ans après le premier vol
commercial faut-il ou non poursuivre
l'exploitation des 4 concorde d'air
france
la réponse par notre spécialiste jean
pierre qui tard il ne faut pas s'étonner
de voir partisans et adversaires de
concorde s'affronter une fois de plus à
propos de la facture du supersonique
il en est et il en ira ainsi à chaque
augmentation des prix du pétrole
pour les uns arrêté au corps ne
servirait à rien dans la mesure où la
flotte supersonique d'air france 4
appareils au total ne brûle que 7 % des
2 millions 600 mille tonnes de
carburants utilisés chaque année par la
compagnie nationale une goutte d'eau
comparée à la consommation nationale
huppés en revanche précise les pros
concorde
les conséquences économiques et surtout
psychologique d'un arrêt de
l'exploitation serait catastrophique non
seulement pour l'image de marque de la
compagnie mais également pour l'image de
marque de la technologie française il
n'est jamais bon
en effet d'arrêter un programme en cours
d'eau
pour les autres en revanche concorde
reste un goujat pétrole qui coûte de
plus en plus cher aux contribuables
france la note sur cette année encore
supérieur à 300 millions de francs cette
somme correspond à l'addition du déficit
d'exploitation proprement dit 99
millions de francs 1978 et à celle des
frais financiers
234 millions de francs l'an dernier des
frais qu'il faudra payer jusqu'en 1993
que l'avion vole ou de vol en outre
ajoute les partisans de l'arrêt si
effectivement à la consommation annuelle
de carburant n'est pas à proprement
parler scandaleuse 180 mille tonnes cela
représente quand même la note de
chauffage de vingt mille maisons
individuelles un argument aussi
psychologique qu'est connaît malgré ces
chiffres et ce déficit il n'est pas
question pour l'instant d'arrêter
concorde dit-on au ministère des
transports air force de son côté dit à
qui veut bien l'entendre qu'elle fera ce
que lui dira de faire le gouvernement
continuait où harry en fait derrière
cette relative indifférence
la compagnie elle aussi fait c'est con
car elle doit lutter contre une
concurrence internationale de plus en
plus vives il ne serait pas étonnant qu
air france utilise ces nouvelles hausses
du pétrole pour réorganiser complètement
son réseau supersonique
en clair supprimer des lignes de
prestige comme mexico caracas et ligne
où les coefficients d'occupation sont
inférieurs à 50% et par contre augmenté
les fréquences sur les deux lignes les
plus rentables new york et rio de
janeiro les deux liaisons sur lesquels
la compagnie équilibre recel et l'époque
cette solution aurait l'avantagé de ne
mécontenter personne qui plus est et à
quelques variantes près c'est la
politique que je suis depuis trois ans
british airways la compagnie nationale
anglaise la deuxième avec air france qui
utilisent et qui possède des cons corps